I will treat that as a good to go now
what I'm going to do really quickly is
show you the way that I think about this
and then hopefully your curve and mind
matches up and then neither of us have
made any silly mistakes so let's have a
look you can see what I've done is I've
taken the equation of the curve that
we're going to graph and I've just
rearranged it slightly to make it clear
what the two transformations are that
have taken place let's do them in
reverse order because the one we just
looked at most recently up above is
about reflection so you can see over
here I have this minus sign attached to
the X that means I'm gonna have the
normal exponential curve but backwards
so it's left to right which means in my
head I don't actually draw this because
I'm familiar enough with this but in my
own head I have this picture appearing
in my head
roughly speaking it's not the actual
graph of course but it means I've got
the overall shape remember that's the
first thing I need to watch for right so
that's gonna be part of my shape and
then secondly over here on the left hand
side this minus one what it really
attaches to is the Y that's where it
belongs and so there's a change
happening vertically and it's going to
be a change it's gonna shift one unit
upward okay now that's very important
for all of our different features that
we need right our intercepts asymptote
our point for scale all of them are
going to move up along with this
vertical translation okay so one I'm
gonna start and do now it's time to do
now is to think about some information
and put them on in that order I might
it'll start with the intercepts right so
when I'm working at the intercept here I
would say I'm looking for a y-intercept
first so I let X equal zero so therefore
I get y equals 3 to the power 0 plus 1
so it's 1 plus 1 which equals 2
that makes sense we normally get a
y-intercept of 1 so I've been moved
upwards so I'm gonna place it at 2 so
let's go ahead actually I'm not I'm not
actually going to put it on there just
yet I don't want to make my scale locked
in until I know the things I'm going to
put on there because I'm you can get
yourself in some trouble with
exponential curves if you realize you
put like 2 somewhere if you put 2 here
and then suddenly you need to point 4
scale somewhere very high and you're
like oh no I don't have enough space on
my Cartesian plane left ok so I'm just
going to file that away I will um I'll
just highlight it over here there's my
y-intercept
okay my asymptotes where is that going
to be well my asymptote is usually at x
equals sorry y equals zero I'm only
getting a horizontal asymptote here at y
equals 0 which is the x axis but we just
said in orange up here I've had a
vertical translation right so along with
the graph the asymptotes also moves up
one unit so instead of being at y equals
zero it's going to be at y equals one so
I'm gonna highlight that as well and
again I'm just keeping that my mind
because I want to draw anything on until
I know where everything's going to fit
lastly let's go ahead and work out a
point for scale
like I said x equals 1 is a pretty nice
value to select if I go x equals 1 I'm
gonna get y equals let's see here 3 to
the power of negative 1 plus 1 remember
your negative indices here this is a
third plus 1 so this is 1 and 1/3 hmm
have a think about this this is actually
beneath our y intercept over here but
that should make sense because remember
from the first time I did a rough sketch
here
it's a decay situation right so that's
why this thing is going lower okay so
now that I know where my graph is going
to head I'm gonna go ahead and I'm going
to actually place some of these piece of
information on here so I'm going to put
it so that I can get my scale decent I'm
gonna put my y-intercept there at 2 now
that I know that's 2 then 1 will be here
which means 1 and 1/3 will be about
looks to me like there yeah I'm pretty
happy with that 1 and 1/3 so when I find
an x value for that it's going to go
across to the right okay so I also have
one last thing which is my Y asymptote
my horizontal asymptote I should say
which is going to go through that one
which I labeled before so I'm gonna draw
my horizontal dotted line here a label
letter so y equals 1 and now I'm ready
okay let's go ahead and put in our curve
like so
Drimmer lines across and this point here
1 and 1/3 collides with air so remember
that's what I got from x equals 1 so
therefore I'm going to
with those coordinates as one comma one
and a third I've got my shape over all
right I've got my intercept got my
asymptotes and my point for scale I'm
finished
okay let's quickly do this one together
again let's have a look at all of the
different features here I'm gonna do
this alive with you maybe you can work
it out alongside me I'm gonna go Y minus
five from both sides so that I can show
that the five is really interacting with
the y etre as we saw before this is
going to be a vertical shift or vertical
translation the graph is going to be
five units higher than it would have
been if it didn't have that minus five
and then you can see over here in the
right-hand side let's go back to orange
again there's actually two things
happening here which is a bit sneaky so
number one you can see that minus sign
that means there's going to be a
reflection oh that's actually cheeky of
me does that really belong there I
actually think the minus sign belongs
elsewhere let me move this down a little
bit I'm going to do it like this because
I'm sorry feeling around myself that's
what I get for doing this first okay
let's move that down I actually think
that minus sign really belongs over on
the other side you can see it's actually
not attached to the X there it's not up
in the index it's actually over on the
other side if I multiply through by that
minus sign that shows this in fact even
the two belongs over there as well so
I'm going to write as minus 1 over 2 e
to the X so you can see here that's
better
what if I go I've got that vertical
shift that I saw before let's get rid of
that orange highlighting because really
it belongs over here there's going to be
not a horizontal reflection but a
vertical reflection because that minus
sign really is closer to the Y then is
to the X it's actually nothing to do
with the index that you can see over
over here you can see that X just kind
of hangs out on its own so therefore in
orange now I'm going to write number one
there's a vertical reflection and
secondly what effect does that division
by to have well there's going to be a
stretch over the Koya as well it's not
just upside down
it's also going to be taller than it
would have been otherwise okay
so now that we're ready to do this I'm
gonna give you I've sort of water you
through how I think about this graph I'm
gonna do it live with you but I'll let
you have a go yourself as well and I
will probably take me about two minutes
to actually draw this on here and then
we'll have a look at my working together
and then you'll have a go at the
exercise okay so off you go I'm still
talking for a second while I actually
think about it and then we'll compare
notes at the end this is what my graph
looks like okay and in fact maybe I
should have done this before but let's
just quickly see what desmos says and
whether we get some agreement from that
so this is five - what did I say it was
- e to the X tada
there we go I'm pretty happy with that
that's not bad alright so how did I come
up with this how did I know that this is
what it was going to look like let's
step through my working a little bit
okay and now it's a bit of a mess so
step through this one one step at a time
for me I'm looking for the shape
intercept asymptotes sorry intercepts
and asymptotes and then a point for
scale if relevant and I'll come back to
the idea of if relevant in a second so
for starters over here on the bottom
left hand corner I know it's really
messy but this is my shape I want to
know roughly what's going to eventuate
out of this curve it's not going to be
your stock standard exponential curve
because of this minus sign at the front
that vertical reflection that I saw
before so I know this thing's going to
look upside down this of course is not
what the actual graph is going to look
like all the rest of the numbers
interact with the graph and transform in
different ways but at least I know this
is roughly what the shape is going to
look like okay so tick I've got that
I'll keep it in the back of my mind and
then move on to the next feature which
is the intercepts okay so I let X equal
0 - go ahead and find a y-intercept I
think most people were ok with that but
with what we had a look at earlier the
first example the first example didn't
have an x-intercept how did I know that
this one would now the short answer is
when I started I wasn't a hundred
percent sure I have graphed a lot of
these so you sort of get more familiar
with the overall shape but let me show
you the two reasons how I knew to do
this number one have a look at my
overall shape over here
okay the overall shape is this downward
looking exponential graph here it's
upside down but then if you recall when
I was having a look at the equation here
I noticed there was a vertical shift and
it's going to be a vertical shift five
units upwards do you remember that that
minus five goes if the axis is moving
down which means the graph is moving up
relative to it so that means if you
think about this graph here in fact I
can literally do it if I take the axes
here watch closely if you're looking at
your workbook right now if I take these
axes and I move them down five units
then you can see you're gonna get this
collision with in fact I don't need to
move the horizontal axis or just need to
sorry the vertical axis I just need to
move this guy down you can see when that
moves five units you get this second
intercept appearing over here in the
bottom right hand corner so that was the
first sort of intuition and the second
thing was when I visualized what would
happen if instead of 20 x equals zero if
I put y equals zero you can fairly
quickly see even before you've worked
out the numbers that you will get a
sensible value for x you've got to pull
out your logs to do it if this line here
if this transition from what's this line
one line to if your transition from line
three to line four is completely
perplexing to you then I would advise
two things number one go and revise your
log Wars and number two do you ask your
teacher for clarification for what's
going on there because you're gonna have
to find values like this a fair bit as
you graph but that's how I worked out oh
there's a sensible X value that goes
with this so I can actually solve it y
equals zero x equals this guy down here
the last piece of information that I
needed before I actually started drawing
was the asymptotes I said there's been a
vertical shift instead of having a
horizontal asymptote at zero I'm gonna
have a horizontal asymptote at five
because it's it's moved up okay now I
said that was the last piece of
information the asymptotes even though I
mentioned earlier all right the start
that we is supposed to have a point four
scale how is it that I can skip that and
the answer is I already have a point
four scale if I have an x intercept
sorry this is my x-intercept and also a
y-intercept when you have a look and
here's my result now when I put it
together when you have a look at this
graph then it can't be any other graph
than the one that I started with
why equals 5 minus 2 e to the X it can't
be any other graph because number one it
can't be any taller or shorter
it can't be stretched out because that
three locks you in vertically but it
also can't be anything wider because
that log of 5 on 2 which is by the way
if it's zero point nine if you're
curious roughly that means that it can't
be any wider either so unlike say you
know this first one that we started with
this guy you have no idea how tall or
short or how wide or how narrow it is
because there are no numbers these
numbers here the Y intercepts and the X
intercepts they tell you everything so
if you've got a pair of intercepts like
that on both axes then you're good to go
no more point for scale required all the
scale is on there last thing that is
worth mentioning before I let you go on
the exercises is please do make sure
your scale is consistent we said this
before but see how this is
whoopsie-daisy see how this y intercept
is 3 well if I'm saying that though the
horizontal asymptote is at y equals 5
then it had better make sense
of my vertical scale here 1 2 there's 3
4 and then 5 so it has to actually line
up if your 5 was way too high or if it
was too close to the 3 then we're
absolutely gonna say this is not an
accurate representation of the graph and
yeah you would not get full marks for
that